[Musique]
être adulte c'est aussi accepter qu'on
est plus un enfant
[Musique]
maman tu frappes avant d'entrer ah oui
pardon taxes et d'amour tu fais quoi
je vais donner tes vieux jouets à enzo
il sera content nous nous montrons temps
je regarde je garde toi pour que tu veux
le garder
tu veux dire que je vais te magne on
arrête avec ça annoncé des figurines
c'est pas des jouets nous autres petits
bourgeois enzo trop petit pour jouer
avec ta part tu extra mutants de
l'espace
c'est n'importe quoi c'est une tortue
ninja 1 et puis c'est pas n'importe qui
c'est leonardo le leader sur sa voix est
pas un peu grand pour jouer avec ces
trucs non ouais
[Musique]
latham la dictée des journées pour moi
il échoue non non et ça c'est quoi au
nom de la collection ça rien à voir si
j'ai quelque chose pour toi quelque
chose de super tu vas voilà tiens c'est
pour toi c'est quoi c'est une main
collante
quand j'étais gamin j'adorais jouer avec
ça là effectivement l école plus trop
mais c'est une main gluante et c'est
super cool
enzo tu sais moi à ton âge j'avais pas
les tablettes
la réalité virtuelle tout ça on voit
tout ce que j'avais c'était une main
collante et ça m'allait très bien
éponger batman
et toi qu'est ce que tu ai répondu maman
oui tu as donné mon batman camouflage de
nu à enzo ont deux petites secondes
dérouille à mon fils de 27 ans qui fait
un caprice aimé ça rien à voir avec un
caprice j'aimerais juste alors pourquoi
tu as donné mon bachmann camouflage de
nuit sont même eux consulter parce que
tu as 27 ans et que ça va bientôt faire
quinze ans que t'as pas toucher à tes
jouets et alors c'est une figurine de
collection à en 15 ans à la double prix
facile on l'a acheté 100 francs eh ben
ça fait 200 francs donc 30 euros trou ok
ouais mais la valeur sentimentale insap
appris ça ce que nous faisons c'est
gentil je trouve ça mieux si nous
parlons est d'amener joie de dire façon
qu'à demander
bah oui voilà enfin quelqu'un avait que
du bon sens dans cette famille moi si ma
maman elle prenait montbéliard doubs
j'ai trop court hier le bateau ginger tu
connais et ceux que je connais et je
connais pas du tout et n'importe quoi
mais c'est pareil mais il faut sortir un
petit peu je raider tu la hausse ayant
figuré c'est quoi verront la prochaine
fois qu'il vient j'espère qu'ils me
demandent de porter le collier de
nouilles qui m'a fait ya 20 ans aux yeux
au nordbank et tu veux je suis aussi
leonardo je suis ton double maléfique du
passé les nuls pour jouer regarde
pourquoi non pas moi j neige de guerre
donc jeter bas est ce qu'une hache de
guerre ça gagne contre un teen aux orres
parfaitement dressés cyber war
allons ce rachat de la branche tu sais
quoi enzo je te file le dinosaure est
aussi ont vu leonardo et même mon dark
vador je vous j'avais planqué dans ma
poche je voulais pas que le filet ça toi
merci
cool leonardo du passé le choix mûri
tous les jeux de passe et je vais les
détruire
sauf auquel tu m'en fais pas c'est
quasiment pas là dernier c'est ma
chambre
un superbe
[Musique]